there you are again
here you are again here we are again
yeah
how are things great no but hey nothing
less but sheer greatness do you ever get
do you ever get down
do you ever get depressed why would i
you're human
for what no hey it's not about that it's
about
every day you're gonna go through
struggles man
every day somebody's gonna test you
somebody's gonna put you through a test
whether that's people or that's god
are you religious in a sense
yeah in a sense i feel like uh
i feel like the bible was man-made you
know
the original bible you can't nobody
knows what that [ __ ]
says nobody all they know is what's
what's been given to them why aren't we
all under one accord why is there
nine different religions ten different
religions
muslim catholic christian mormon
why aren't we under one flag
why is it that the people or whoever
this may be
separate us into haves and have-nots
almost
what you think mark yeah i think
religion's a great way to separate
people
[Music]
i don't want to separate myself from
nobody
who makes us any better than these
people that are outside this door man
they listen they need to stop
treating these people like rodents
start treating them like people they
might start acting i think if we all
treat each other with dignity and
respect
it would change a lot of things they
would all mark
they would all stop treating people like
that
start treating them like people versus
treating them like rodents
you wonder why they act like that people
only act the way they're treated man
i'm a firm believer in that i get it
that people try to say that uh
you can build your own destiny build
your own
fate no man it takes a helping hand from
the people that are around you
as simple as your mother and your father
who he plays perfect in this world
who he more who plays perfect
man i can live in the best neighborhood
in the world
i've seen your average i'm talking about
looks like they've never done
nothing in their entire life you think
they don't got any skeletons in their
closet hell you got skeletons in your
closet we all do
everybody man has a sense of some type
of
darkness or a sense of some [ __ ]
that somebody made up it's all labels
man
bad because they labeled you bad no this
is life we all
are gonna go through life
when are we going to wake the [ __ ] up
you know i was uh
i was talking to somebody this morning
you know and i uh
i got a extradited on the charge one
time and i was
headed down south and um
i told him you know it's crazy because i
was sitting next to this
this big i'm talking about this big
white man [ __ ] i don't know if he was
racist or not but i know me and him was
stuck on this bus for the next seven
days
this little ass van it's a little ass
van man
and we're sitting next to each other on
this bench and we're shackled up for the
next seven
eight days until you know because
pickups were more important than
drop-offs
so you know they had only a certain
amount of time to pick you up it was
never really no set time when they drop
you off so long story short i'm sitting
there with this man and uh
we've been riding for like three full
days at this point you know we tired
and it's a white man i don't know if he
racist i don't know if he even like
[ __ ] or anybody that's even in the
same skin color as me but i told him
listen man
we tired you want to use my shoulder for
a couple hours i use your shoulder for a
couple hours and we worked that out
just so we can get some type of rest
maybe me and this man we and i've never
seen him again every day in my life
but at that given moment we were able to
separate color we were able to separate
who has what
money who has the most this the most
that and we were able to come together
just two people and lean on one another
just do people
just two people man just two people we
don't know each other from adam and eve
hell we me and him can already
understand that we probably never see
each other again a day in our lives
so your parents were mixed black and
white
yeah my dad my dad was black my mom was
white
and you you see yourself as either or
just some mix i mean to be honest being
a mixed man you know you'll never be too
much
white for the white crowd you'll never
be too much black for the black crowd so
maybe that's where i tried to find my
own happy medium
i don't want to go the way everyone else
is going i want to go
my way i'm gay i'm glad that
god blessed me with that gift to be able
to have the
enough courage and what you would say
charisma
to go my way
to go my way doesn't matter what i do
these are labels
man these are labels that
the community and society has made to
make it see fit to make sense of it
you'll never make sense of life man
all you can do is continue to keep going
and to continue to keep
learning it's the problem with people
they don't they're not willing to learn
anything anymore
when someone like myself can possibly
come and spread awareness
i see it in the comments on the on the
videos on my channel where people will
make these comments
stating facts about people that they're
making guests guesses about and anytime
you're stating a fact like saying you
are a good guy or a bad guy or whatever
we
really don't know about any of them you
ask me okay well you know what's so
called is because
people make all these assumptions right
and i'm about to use your question as a
good standpoint here
make all these assumptions but they
never
just ask just like you did right now
they don't know so are you asking me
so so are you asking me am i do i feel
it's not even about what i feel but are
you asking me am i a good guy or a bad
guy no
i don't i don't even think about it yeah
because you're probably both like i am
we're all both at different times of the
day week year month whatever
who's good who more
i mean you're trying to try to do some
good things in your life yeah
you know some you i'm sure you know some
some very great men in your life as well
as i do who's perfect man
who who do you know man that don't have
not at least one flaw
one flaw in their life
we can't act like we've [ __ ] been
here before man let's stop the [ __ ]
let's cut the drag okay let's cut the
[ __ ]
let's not act like we've been here i
know i haven't
i'm willing to learn every day
that's why my mind expands the way it
does
i sit and spend i sit and spend a lot of
time
by myself more a lot of time
to where i get to enlighten even myself
i love to learn i don't people
yeah that's people want to learn anymore
it's that appetite for learning that
makes you grow in makes you unique makes
you interesting
it makes you unique [ __ ] interesting
then you're also you you like i think
you
we think for the for ourselves
i like i never listened my entire life i
never listened to anyone else telling me
how things are would you consider that a
character flaw
no it's the opposite exactly it's the
opposite
exactly no it's like you know when just
because everybody's doing something
doesn't
it almost was a sign that you shouldn't
do that in my book
[ __ ] with you mark i do bro
[ __ ] with you you're an interesting dude
because
probably more than anybody on my channel
you get positive comments and negative
comments both
some people think you're the greatest
thing to ever walk the earth you're
amazing and interesting and other people
think you're
you're awful and evil and all that and i
get the same thing
and that's pure goal i think that's pure
gold it just makes you interesting
you know i never really fed off of it
in a
[Music]
term to where i feel like it's a sense
of fame i feed off of it to wear just to
let them know that i truly don't give a
[ __ ] church i don't give two [ __ ] three
if they really need it
i don't care what they think
i say this right if uh
the world ended tomorrow they took these
tapes and they took everything that ever
meant to this [ __ ] world
they stuffed it all in a box right
i want them that the newfound glory of
people or whoever the [ __ ] it is that
comes about right
i want to be able to find this tape
right here
this tape right here
and let them know that there was still
some people
who thought like this before you got
here
no matter what i do no matter what i do
what i've done
did that really [ __ ] matter mark
i don't think so i don't think it
matters not one bit
what matters is what we did
before anything in our lives
anything what we did it's not about
where you went to the next bar you went
playing around you went just
trying to go through your life and just
know
make it meaningful
make it legendary
it's not about the money for me it's not
about the money
to me being legendary
is bringing truth
because i'm already noticing out in this
world people are already having us
they're already forgetting
they away with it
they don't even remember it anymore you
know what they do they put it on a tape
and they store it in a vault
they don't remember it and carry it who
had the most impact on you
as a kid
people who were trying to do more than
their living status
having a sense of charisma or sense of
courage to understand that yeah we're
we're living [ __ ] up but it doesn't
mean that we have to
drowned in our sorrow
how many people have you met from skid
row church that drowned in their sorrow
huh they drowned in it man saturate
themselves in it
they bathe in it that's what they clean
themselves in they clean themselves
daily with it
i've been there man slept in cars
i've done all that
that don't mean [ __ ] i don't mean a
[ __ ] thing
why do you think i'm not here to tell
you where i've been
i'm here to tell you where i'm going
baby
here to tell you where i'm going
you think nobody out here nobody i don't
give a [ __ ] if it's you
it's me none of us have a br i've had a
breaking point to where it gets
[ __ ] up it's what you do to come out
of it
remember when i said back in the first i
think it was the first one i said
something about man crabs in a bucket
right
we're all just trying to get our crabs
never get out the bucket man
transform yourself
that's a gift that we all have we all
lose it though somewhere down the line
but you know what
you got to learn how to go get it back
that's what makes you strong
go and get it back you're gonna have to
do a t-shirt with your crabs in the
bucket quote
hey man uh listen i i promise you
i never started to do these interviews
to
sell merge to gain any money
it's not about gaining money
it's about spreading awareness
that not everybody is playing
said it before and i'll say that again
not everybody's playing not everybody is
your
perfect idiot
you're a perfect idiot running around no
god made millions and billions of people
for a reason he
he's trying to get it right even himself
he's trying to get it right even himself
no one's perfect man
that was the case he would have left it
adam and eve
no one's perfect
what mistakes have you made that you've
learned from in your life
you remember when i said uh
do what makes you happy don't don't do
something for somebody because
it appeases them at the time and i fell
victim to that myself
at my early years you know in my life
doing something i learned that with
parents and just
doing something they want you it's as
simple as that man
you know that's not a mama issue or a
daddy issue i'm kind of glad that i
got that lesson because it helped me out
later on down
the long run even though i don't [ __ ]
with my mama thank you
and i love you because you made me
something that's
not to be [ __ ] with
where'd you get personality from mom or
dad or somebody else or
from life man life no one gets there
listen to me man you look like your mama
and your daddy
you die like the decisions looking like
the decisions
that you made you'll never die
looking like them or anything that they
had in a trait no man this is on you
you're just born looking like them
this is your choice
mark when you die no one's gonna say oh
well he did this like his mom or he did
this like his dad guess what they're
gonna talk about
only you only you
who you think they're going to talk
today i'll talk about your parents
half the [ __ ] is going to be at
your funeral i'm going to know your
parents
to even talk about them
they're only going to talk about you
whether it was your good or your bad
you die looking like the decisions that
you made
you never die looking like your parents
you're only born looking like
let's talk about the game a little bit
what are the
what's the biggest misconception about
this
game of pimps and hoes that you
play around in
it's not really about what i play around
in it's what i've observed throughout my
time
having to deal with people you know and
i understand that times change
times change [ __ ] hell cell phones
change right you know they go from one
year to another
but there were certain things that still
had code to a mark
still had structure had [ __ ]
body you know
now it gets watered down
like a soda that you left in the car
with a bunch of ice in it and now
it's got that whole clear part at the
top and you take a sip and you try to
get down to the sugary part of it then
it's no longer there but i think my
question is kind of
a lot of people make the assumption
probably incorrect assumption that
it's all about guys exploiting women
simple as that it's not about that bad
exploiting that's what i'm saying so
people exploit every day hell pepsi
exploits yeah no but coca-cola exploits
but
i'd love to hear your explanation of how
how that misconception is
listen what it looks like in reality
i'll say this
this and i've said this before man it
used to be a secret society man it was
ninjas in the making you never saw never
saw us you never heard the things that
you see
people getting years and beating women
burning women uh
just doing cruel things to people that's
nowhere near part of the game mark
nor has it ever been people took that
terminology you know
i start to see that a lot of people that
like to
hurt people or
misuse people they use the game
as a as a reason of why they're doing
this to this person and that's not okay
if that makes any sense that's not okay
beating this woman though this is just
really how you wanted to be because you
had issues
but people use the game as a crutch
people use the game as a crush oh well
this is why i do it to you because
i'm this or this is why i do it to you
because i'm that no you do that because
you're a [ __ ] up individual
that's what you want to do it's what you
chose to do that's what's nasty
it's not me that's what's nasty
i'm free-spirited baby
oh i'm this heart runs free
however it needs to be
however it needs to be the spirit runs
free
and let's not ever get that [ __ ] up
when they want to sit there and say oh
and the tabloids and
you know people talk about men they put
me on all types of different
sites and [ __ ] like that whether it's
good or bad you know and
it don't make me none i'm here to tell
my story because guess what
when you open up my book i'm the
illustrator the editor
publisher i'm everything in the book of
my life
they can't tell me [ __ ] [ __ ] them
i said before mark suck my balls through
the reason i asked that question is
because i'll read something good draws
the reason i ask that question is
because i'll see some comments sometimes
on your videos saying things that are
probably
very out of line with who you really are
because i've talked with your girls i've
talked
i see how you operate i don't think
you're anywhere near what they're
thinking you are
yeah well know about the girl part
and the extra [ __ ] but you've talked to
me you know
you've watched what me and you've done
throughout this time
hopefully we got a couple more to come
we'll keep it moving man keep it solid
hey man
i stand up for society never hurt nobody
doesn't matter how i
dress what i drink out of what i smoke
none of that
you got way worse people in the world
man that stand with collar tie and
everything with glasses
fixing them at the nerdy that's doing us
evil
so please don't put it on my back
don't put it on my back love politics
too
i watch the news too every day that's
probably the most interesting thing you
said and probably the truest thing
you've said
i'm just being honest man i think you're
right you don't think you got gang
members and pimps and [ __ ] drug
dealers and everything throughout this
and we don't even need to go there
because i don't want him to target me
i don't want him to do me like johnny
carson or people that spoke up in the
past or martin luther king i don't want
him to do that man
they shunned us long time ago man
anything that was like me that was
created
was to help the community my man
it was never to hurt it but you know
the government had to have a fall guy
someday
they had to paint an ugly picture for
something
that's what gets it off their back i
think a lot of people are very
uncomfortable with
prostitution in general and rather than
putting away a bunch of girls that are
working the streets they decided that
putting away a lot of the guys that are
granted right granted that's what they
do
slave you 400 years 500 years
600 years i don't know it just goes on
and on man
they don't surprise me anymore and what
they hand out
it doesn't surprise me anymore even
though those numbers are [ __ ]
outlandish what does kenny call him
football numbers
bro further than that we're talking
about baseball numbers
major leagues
but but i will say this that you know
i understand guys like you and kenny rad
and the bishop and and
and a lot a lot of the respected guys in
the game
[Music]
live in a very different level than
these guys that are what we call tennis
show pimps or whole hustlers that are
just on the street selling girls that
are doing this kind of work
i'm titling them all pimps but to some
people's
definition tennis shoe pimp is a stadium
listen when i when i talked about tennis
shoe pimping
when you had asked me that question
before you had said something about uh
what do you think about all these tennis
shoe people i interviewed called them
hoe hustlers which is a great
but to me tennis shoe pimping is a
state of mind it's not what you
necessarily have on your feet
it's a state of mind it's a way that you
live you hustle for a few dollars a day
to me what i've seen lately is
and this is just me watching from the
outside
i don't i'm nowhere baby
nowhere but delaware
what do i know but the things that i see
from afar
is [ __ ] out here doing it for
a style
you're a fad
it's more of a style like how much are
you doing this for the star
are you doing it so you can do it for a
better life
to get moving can't do it forever
we can't do it forever man
so to sit there and i'm talking to the
ones that inspire to be
around that or move and groove hey
church if you're going to do it man you
got to do it right man
don't be playing with it zip up i think
guys like you and me zip your zip
hey church zip your pants up and stand
up for what you mean
i think guys like you and me both along
for the days of the
yeah but but mark you can't be zipping
your pants down you gotta zip it up
church so she can really see what you're
talking
about man because see she know that
there's listen
a woman can get dick from anywhere
a man can't get [ __ ] from anywhere and
if he does he gotta pay for it
but a woman can get it for free at any
given time so when do we learn
to get it up for real and have that
better understanding
gotta zip it up man
let her like you and [ __ ] with you from
your mind
not for more oh i can spin this oh well
i can do this no let her like you from
your mind
brother if that's a woman you're trying
to wife or
be a girlfriend boyfriend whatever
keep it in that entity
don't try to cross over to everybody
else's because see there's gonna be
people like me that like a lot of elbow
space
and there's no room for you
not if you plan there's no room for you
george
you been in love before yeah yeah you
know how i know
you know how i know i've been in love i
fall in love every day
every day you know what when
life cause i don't have to be here god
can take me right
god now take me right now hell yeah i've
been in love i'm in love every day
with life you've been in love with a
woman before
i've ever been in love with a woman love
whatever me and her could ever be
have you ever been in love with the
woman thought you have okay then
so you know what i'm saying that don't
mean nothing i'm not sure we're saying
the same until no
i'm saying the exact same thing that
you're saying you just don't know it
you haven't you haven't you haven't felt
it yet you haven't seen it
never given a woman your all your
everything hey listen
okay i wanna say this too many times i'm
gonna say this
and i don't even be one to talk about
but there's a famous lawyer right
that people know because i don't want to
talk about nobody's name because i'm
going nobody's suing me
but uh there was a famous lawyer that
had a wife that we all know today that
had kids that they're all famous today
and this man took care of her this man
took care of her
paid her rent paid her life she never
had to work for nothing she never had to
clean for nothing treated her right in
the
mother man the woman still cheated she
still cheated
after everything there was never no
[ __ ] to where it was anything said
about him
nothing he passed away it was deceased
there was nothing ever bad ever said
about this man
but while she was with him she still
cheated
what's that tell you so that means you
can be good
you can be bad
the [ __ ] gonna be the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] gonna be the [ __ ] man all you
can do is just be
you be who you really are
it goes back to say don't
change up to be with somebody be you
because if they [ __ ] with you they gonna
[ __ ] with you at least you won't feel
bad
church when you find out the dirty harry
because don't it always come you've had
your heart broke more than you've been
in love boy
and count it up yeah look up real quick
i think
i think the number is the same yeah i
think oh man trust me
it outweighs a man love is love
shouldn't have shouldn't happen too many
times
no you shouldn't shouldn't right yeah
maybe maybe three so your calculation is
very often
yes your calculation is very off for me
cause love shouldn't happen too many
times
shouldn't happen too many times sir
what's been going on with you man talk
to me
i'm doing good i'm doing good having fun
what you've been up to lately i was in
this last week
trying to see you but we didn't get
together but you came out here it was
busy you like
you guys no i've been uh been staying up
in uh
delaware in the mountains
i think i think there's gonna be big
things it's been nice up there i've been
raising llamas
i think there's gonna be big things for
your future i think so yep
it's nice hopefully you wanna talk about
what you have up your sleeve or we're
gonna keep it a surprise
i say uh give it a surprise yeah i say
keep it a surprise i think so too
yeah i think so i'm happy for you though
yeah yeah
you just thank you yeah you deserve it
it's gonna be nice
it's nice to see a detroit boy do good
you know i wish uh i wish i would've
knew it was like uh
growing up around there for real man you
know i got a lot of family from there
and everything you know
i've talked to them throughout the years
and [ __ ] like that you know what i've
i've been around there i [ __ ] around
but
it ain't nothing like being from the
west i love this [ __ ] man
i believe this [ __ ] every day i love
being from where i'm from
i like both yeah like i i relate really
deeply to being a chicagoan
and a detroiter and then i love
california
you know what i notice it uh
it makes you who you are
going different places man bouncing you
know you can
you can't really pick your life mark
you can't pick how it's gonna land for
you
yeah they they try to say oh you go to
school you do this right you do that
you ever notice [ __ ] go to hey
[ __ ] go to school
talk about they got college degrees but
listen i disagree with that i think you
can totally listen but listen to this
[ __ ] that got college degrees
right catch themselves getting job after
job
after job after job
after job but want to talk
bad about somebody yeah that's what i
catch
if you want to know how i feel about it
[ __ ] who sit there and say oh i
got college degrees oh i got it
yeah but you catch yourself working
deadbeat jobs
still so what did that all do for you
nothing you catch yourself over in this
hand there's nothing
you catch yourself over here and this
hand is nothing you put them together
[Laughter]
[ __ ] stop playing yourself in life
i'm sorry but i have to say it it's just
in me man and not on me
it really is and it don't [ __ ] matter
what i do
how i've gotten down that ain't what
they're interested in they're interested
in how i made it
out
how did he from somewhere so low
[Music]
that's what it is that's what burns
inside him baby
i'm dead ass serious laugh mark no i
think you're i think
i'm for no i'm i'm i'm dead ass serious
don't even play because i'm for real and
you and i both know it cause they've
watched it
they've watched it in the making
they're going to watch a little bit more
yeah now you got you got a
long long road ahead of you i think oh
man a lot of interesting things coming
from your way
yes i do but but i disagree with you
about you can't like
make your own life and it's all laid out
for you i believe you can totally change
the direction in your life
you could change your direction you're
doing it but you know what a lot of
people don't know how to do it
from ground base no they don't for sure
that's the problem yeah they don't know
how to do it from ground base it's
selective few
i'm one of those selective fields you
know i'm going to
embark on that that journey
it's a fraction of a window that
god or anybody else will give you in
life
no one to take it no one to take it
cherish it and keep it forever
boy you were one of the realest
you ain't with nobody phony
and i ain't never told no lie
all right sure interesting as always
i'll see you again can't wait yeah
you're always fun you get more fun
interactive this this is a this is a
good one
yeah you're getting better and sharper
all the time
all right man good seeing you you too
thank you
you